it starts from the beginning nobody told
me to win when women 17. I just did it
power
mental strength that's how I would
describe Boris he was like Michael
Jordan in Germany
expectations in tennis court becoming
Superstar Sports you're now a wanted man
to pick a black woman as his wife was a
big deal in the German press it was a
black and white thing when you step away
from the game you come into completely
different lights it's sort of walking
into a dark room
she came in she had to be coat on and
she took the coat off she was heavily
pregnant we just can't believe it
all came very late
I think two and a half years in jail for
hiding assets during bankruptcy I've hit
my bottom that's not the end yet there's
going to be another chapter